un million d'espèces menacées c'est le
chiffre de la journée
j'allais me dire c'est pas la première
fois qu'on en parle des dangers qui
guettent la biodiversité
n'empêche c'est un rapport de l'onu
gigantesque qui a été remis aujourd'hui
qui parlent de déclin sans précédent
il ya 145 experts qui ont travaillé dans
50 pays
pour arriver à cette conclusion du
million d'espèces menacées
ils savent a vraiment dans tous les sens
cette menace menace d'extinction carole
% des espèces d'amphibiens 33% les
récifs coralliens très important 33%
également mammifères marins et puis 25
pour ça menacé d'extinction des
vertébrés intéresse ou si le phénomène
dindin des nouveaux arrivés nous vous
arrive à des algues des petits animaux
qui détruisent tout sur leur passage des
espèces exotiques envahissantes qui
déborde de leur milieu et qui menacent
donc les équilibres de la vie
pourquoi les cinq cause rapidement
l'utilisation des terres agriculture
déforestation exploitation des
ressources pêche chasse changement
climatique
on parlait des coraux la mère qui se
réchauffe les pollutions en général et
puis finalement les espèces invasives
viennent en parler avec nous jean lemire
biologiste qui a fait le tour de la
planète sur votre bateau
vous connaissez bien ces choses là vous
êtes d'ailleurs il me sert pour orly
nations unies bon qu'avant la
biodiversité la partons du début c'est
l'autre grand champ d'expertisé
il ya les changements climatiques et la
biodiversité exactement on entendu
parler du giec vous savez ce groupe
intergouvernemental qui qui utilisaient
les changements climatiques la l'autre
groupe c'est ce qu'on appelle lib baisse
donc c'est la même chose de paul et pour
la biodiversité
donc ce sont ces rapports scientifiques
qui sont amassés analyser et qui donne
résumé vraiment concret pour les
décideurs qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est
ce qu'on fait maintenant
un million ça nous paraît gigantesque
vous ça vous surprend pas bah en fait
nous on le savait en fait ce rapport
compile un paquet d'études scientifiques
qu'on connaissait depuis longtemps nous
étions par exemple en egypte en décembre
dernier pour la coop sur la biodiversité
et là on se dirige vers la coop en chine
en vain
et là c'est le grand moment c'est là où
on va se servir de ce rapport et on va
essayer surtout de d'arriver avec des
solutions concrètes pour essayer de
changer la trajectoire donc le
diagnostic est clair ya plein d'éléments
vivant qui meurent qui n'arrivent plus à
vivre le côté lumineux ces conditions
recréer des conditions idéales
ça peut reprendre assez vite est-ce que
c'est pas ça la solution des parcs
protéger des aires marines protégées de
plus en plus exactement il faut
restaurer et il faut également protégé
ça est ce que le rapport dit c'est que
il n'est pas trop tard on peut encore
agir il faut agir maintenant
il y aura en vain en chine des nouvelles
cibles pour les aires protégées au temps
t rès que marine et ça évidemment ça va
demander une implication encore une fois
de tous les pays
ce qui est intéressant dans le rapport
aussi c'est qu'on nous dit sa vie ce ne
sont pas juste les grandes puissances
les communautés locales
les savants autochtones tout ça st et on
se rend bien compte que leur exemple le
québec c'est devant les changements
climatiques du mmo vous savez on a peu
d'influencé l'an biodiversité c'est
presque en un très très grande influence
on à 1.6 million de kilomètres carrés et
donc on peut jouer un rôle très
important et protéger protéger davantage
ce qui pourrait vous dire c'est à
l'armée on va trouver des technologies
pour faire face à ça à chaque année puis
ça va aller on peut continuer à manger
autant viande a circulé autant que ses
terres vous répondre non je pense que
c'est pas la technologie qui vont nous
sauver je pense qu'on est vraiment rendu
à une étape où ça va prendre un
changement des valeurs sociétales est ce
si important et je pense qu'on est rendu
là je pense qu'on peut regrouper
également des choses comme la lutte
contre les changements climatiques et la
lutte pour la préservation de la nature
la biodiversité
quand on regarde les solutions qui sont
proposées c'est des solutions qui
s'applique aux deux problématiques dont
klaus intéressant parce que l'on peut
arriver avec des projets de société
vos équipes par exemple
couvert ce qui s'est passé au danemark
avec eux ils ont décidé que dans les
hôpitaux et dans les écoles c'était de
la bouffe bio local mais là qu'est ce
que ça fait c'est une porte une
politique de santé publique quelque part
parce que c'est de la prévention ça
coupe les gaz à effet de serre parce que
beaucoup moins de transport c'est un
programme d'éducation et plus on va
arriver avec des projets comme ça
structurant pour la société plus on va
faire des gains moi je pense que plus on
voit faire l'équivalence entre
l'environnement et la santé publique
plus on va embarquer public parce que
c'est un problème de communication d'où
ce parce que ultima
c'est la sixième extinction s'il ya plus
de biodiversité c'est des espèces meurt
c'est la fin c'est intéressant dans le
rapport on ne le mentionne pas ce mot
sixième extinction parce que
théoriquement ça s'apprend 75% de
disparition des espèces
mais ce qu'on nous dise que au rythme où
on va en ce moment on se dirige vers ça
donc c'est intéressant parce que là on a
vraiment un signal d'alarmé de la
science il va falloir faire quelque
chose
les modèles actuels ne pouvons pas
supporter une augmentation de population
en ce moment il ya un tiers de la
surface terrestre qui sert élever du
bétail ou à faire de l'agriculture
si on est 10 11 milliards le modèle de
fonctionnaires via marche plus vous avez
fait vos tour du monde c'est quelque
chose que vous constatez facilement ça
cette réduction de la biodiversité
absolument même quand on a décidé de
faire cette dernière mission sur trois
ans on s'était dit on va amener jusqu'au
bout très positifs et ont été frappés
par certaines horreurs et ça nous aurait
plus déprimé il faut l'avouer et donc on
est obligé de dénoncer davantage qu'on
voulait faire on départ mais il faut
jamais oublier également que nous dans
nos congrès de scientifiques etc
on est il faut pas penser qu'on est la
masse nous ce qu'on voyait là à chaque
jour c'est des gens qui en se levant le
matin leur priorité c'est trouver de la
nourriture pour les enfants
donc quand on voit par exemple que les
récifs coralliens sont menacés comme ils
le sont en ce moment c'est à la base
de toute la chaîne alimentaire marine il
ya plus d'un milliard d'humains qui
dépendent du poisson comme apport
protéinique donc qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec ces gens là il va falloir je pense
développer maintenant une notion de
citoyen du monde beaucoup plus grande
avec un système de partage et de valeurs
qui vont faire que le bien commun va
prendre de plus en plus chacun sur la
planète soit conscient les coraux rouges
très bon exemple
il se meurt à complètement complètement
et en plus on est dans des projections à
terme audition si on atteint une
augmentation qui se stabilise à 2 degrés
il y aura une augmentation de la perte
de biodiversité de 5% mais si on se rend
à 4.3 l'on est à 16 pour ça c'est que si
exponent 6 tout ça il ya des gens qui
roulent aussi le débat est très polarisé
sur l'environnement biodiversité ça sera
la même chose qui dise oui il va le
sauver des greno et puis derrière dans
le rapport on parle beaucoup des
grenouilles pas ça puis ridiculise ça
dure c'est pas grave on s'en fout mais
perdre les grenouilles c'est perdre
quelque chose à la chaîne qui est
important c'est énorme
1 ils vont manger plein plein d'insectes
qui volent évidemment pour la
propagation d'une maladie par exemple ça
va nous affecter
on s'en sert beaucoup en pharmacologie
pour les médicaments
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que la
nature c'est pas un endroit où on voit
relaxer le week-end la nature ont fait
partie de ça et tout est interrelié et
nous nous sommes un maillon de la chaîne
ont seuls on se loge grâce à la
biodiversité on se nourrit on se prenait
janvier vie donc c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre et st patrice ça va être la
communication exactement appuyez votre
défi c'est 2002 mieux je vous lis
scientifiques de mieux communiquer quand
justement parce que le débat politique
on voit beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas
un très gros programmes verts se font
élire sur la planète parce que les gens
pensent à leur emploi vous l'avez dit
c'est à vous à mieux nous expliquer
aussi absolument absolument il faut
mieux communiquer il faut en même temps
investir dans l'éducation et le cheval
de nos jeunes cons et on est en train de
leur donner des valeurs qui sont
différentes et ce seront eux qui auront
le pouvoir de m
ça c'est essentiel important et on le
voit là où ça va bien sur la planète les
pays scandinaves exceptés
ils ont misé beaucoup sur les u15
l'éducation alors ça c'est vraiment une
source d'avenir merci jean lemire d'être
nous nous en parle on va en reparler
comme dit ce rapport là va être au
centre d'une grande conférence en chine
pour en reparler
merci merci à me revoir